[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's bring in tony beceli who
worked uh radio color for last night's
game on westwood one with the lions and
the packers tony thanks for joining us
um let me start with the taunting part
of this how much of it is just part of
the game and how much of this should we
be getting or trying to get rid of
oh i think it's part of the game i mean
you know
i think we've gone too far i mean i love
the fact that we
you know fans media everybody you know
complains about players not caring
enough we want emotion and we want guys
you know getting after and playing with
their hair on fire but then we want to
draw this line that you can't
celebrate or
express yourself in a intense physical
emotional game
you can't have it both ways and i think
you have to let guys have a little bit
of fun out there that's part of it i
mean
dan you i mean growing up playing sports
if you're on the basketball court you
know playing a pickup game you're
telling me there's no taunting out there
you go drop a three in someone's face
you're letting them know you know you
get a big block i mean we were running
running our mouths the whole time and i
think the nfl
they're trying to stop it from going to
the next level and so maybe they're
trying to get in front of it but i think
they're trying to get in front of it too
early and uh they've gone too far do
linemen talk trash
oh yeah but you can't it's harder for
them to tell because we're so close
together
um
that you know we're in the trenches
things are said things are done um
there's gamesmanship i mean think of
some of the all-time greats i mean the
top the one that comes you know
top of mind is john randall you know
he's got his face face painted up he's
you know chatting up the whole time he
used to go
read the
program in like the bios of guys and
start running you know running you know
running his mouth and you know talking
calling people out and the problem with
john was he could back it up
he'd be beating you up physically and
mentally he had the whole game i'm just
wondering why now for the nfl it always
it feels like the nfl goes hey
nobody's talking about this let's talk
about this they they did this with
what's a catch what's a football move
like can the ground cause a fumble
i i grew up at a time watching the nfl i
i never worried about that thought about
that now you have all this instant
replay now they don't even get the calls
right with instant replay and now we're
gonna ask these officials and you played
this game
in a split second try to tell us what
intent is like you meant to do something
whether you did or not and that's going
to be 15 yards i i just don't understand
they have so many other things to worry
about
yeah i i must have missed like the
national crisis of taunting going on in
the nfl where there was an outrage and
op-eds being written and people like
just
protesting in the streets because nfl
players were
talking smack and getting into each
other's faces i
i agree with you dan i think sometimes
we used to go too far like i think the
nfl has done a good job of trying to
make the game as safe as possible which
is really a misnomer because football's
never going to be safe but let's take
out the head shots let's take out
leading with the helmet let's let's
teach the game the right way i'm all
that that makes sense but some of these
ancillary things they focus on i think
it's a distraction i don't think the
fans like it i don't think the fans want
it um
the last thing you want is because
someone gets up and celebrates someone
else's face you want that to impact or
change the outcome of a game fans don't
want that players don't want it coaches
don't want to i'm trying to understand
who
in the new york offices
wants this like what is why what what
made this such a
a important issue that we needed to
address it he's tony biselli former jags
offensive tackle and uh he was on the
call radio wise for westwood one last
night detroit and green bay i guess
everything's all good with the packers
oh it's all fixed i mean just
just ignore
what happened uh it was almost like they
forgot that we were playing 17 regular
season games and they thought that was
the fourth preseason game against the
saints opening weekend
i mean that i mean it was it was one of
the worst performances forget about it
being aaron rodgers and a team that you
expect the challenge to go to the super
bowl i mean it was just bad football no
emotion opening day now i still think
they got some significant issues aaron
rodgers by the way is not one of them um
i think that defense
is
um does not have a lot of talent i don't
think they can rush the passer knows
darius smith he's going to be out a
short term on ir because he's back he's
their best bash rusher preston smith's a
nice player but they don't win up front
um i know looking at that game last
night that
joe berry the new defensive coordinator
he can't just rush for and play coverage
uh and so they they're gonna have to
figure out what they're gonna do and i
think they're gonna have to outscore
people this year if they're gonna really
have a lot of success
yeah i wondered about that
can they do that because now you go to
san francisco this next week so
new orleans it's a nightmare it's a
crisis uh you know five alarm fire then
you beat the lions and you're favored by
11.
you're supposed to beat them nothing
happened last night where i went oh wow
look at the packers
now i want to know how you respond when
you go to san francisco i think this
game will tell me a whole lot more than
the first two games of the season what
do you think about that for the packers
going out to san francisco
well yeah i think you're right because
if you look at the game last night i
mean into the third quarter
the lions had moved the ball up and down
the field the factors had not been able
to really stop them they're struggling
against stopping the run a bad fourth in
one call by the lions really changed
that entire game either they kick a
field goal there or they convert and you
know it's a back and forth game who
knows what happens they're gonna go
they're gonna go to san francisco with a
now san francisco's beat up in the
backfield they have a lot of running
backs i don't know who's going to be
back there but they have a great scheme
kyle shanahan may be one of the best
running game coordinators uh in all the
nfl and they're going to go after him
and
i think that this is a great test for
the defense and also
they're playing a good front four
nick bose is only going to get feeling
better and better coming off that knee
injury
i'm really interested and i think you're
dead on this is the really uh this will
be a good barometer to see what what
kind of packers team we're going to see
this year but also tampa bay goes to the
rams as well
you're going to oh great i mean you talk
about great games uh
tampa is the most tampa bay is probably
the most interesting team i think
they're the best all-around team because
offense defense what they're able to do
um and i'm
dan i've been sold whatever diet what's
it called tb12 i'm going to start it
tomorrow
anybody who
gets better at 44 and continues like
he's better than he was when he was 24.
um i i i it's unbelievable i mean we
talk all the time father times
undefeated well he just took his first l
and tom brady's the one who delivered it
and that's a good team i mean they got
offensive weapons um
i think they're not playing great
defense yet but i i i believe in that
defense so i think you have the rams of
stafford you know sean mcveigh's got his
guy that was a big move in the offseason
so
two of the better teams in nfc might be
it might be a preview of the nfc
championship
how would it be to block for brady
if is he the ideal quarterback to block
for
uh i think so i think for a left tackle
yeah because he's so good in the pocket
and what i think gets lost is subtle
movements help his offensive line and so
you know offensive linemen he gets beat
a little bit in the inside he just
shuffles and he doesn't sprint out of
there causing trouble for everybody else
he just shuffles two or three steps buys
time uh and finds you know the guy down
the field so he's one of the best ever
um
you know there's extra pressure if
you're playing offensive line and tom
brady's back there because you got the
one of the greatest of all time if not
the greatest the last thing you want to
be is the guy who gets him knocked
around a little bit but yeah he'd be a
lot of fun to play for what's that like
when the quarterback gets sacked and
it's because of you
and do you go over and help the
quarterback up or say nothing
no you want to help them up but then you
just you realize that you don't want to
look up at the video board because you
realize you're showing a replay you're
trying to ignore the defense because
they're doing some sack dance um and
you're just hoping like somehow that
the guy who's shooting the game the film
guy for your team like lost that clip so
you have to watch it tomorrow it's it's
one of the worst feelings in the entire
world because you know that every bit of
focus is on you and there's uh and it's
not like you know you play another
position a defensive back or running
back or receiver where you can go make
up for it the next play like there's
nothing i can do on the next play that
says oh he redeemed himself no i just go
block the guy and everyone forgets about
it
did you ever face a defensive lineman
and just say
this is
it
maybe not overmatched but i'm i'm in
trouble here today
you know
the only the closest time ever was we
were playing on a sunday night and uh we
were good but we weren't we were playing
the vikings who were great and john
randall who i was talking about earlier
was playing defensive end and we had our
third string quarterback and it was just
it went bad early and i just realized
immediately like this is not going to be
a fun night it's just going to it's just
going to be one of those opera one of
those nights when you hope the clock
goes really really fast because um
we don't have much of a chance to win
this game and uh
it's a bad feeling and there's nothing
worse there's nothing let me say this
there's nothing better unfortunately
this was most of my career that's how i
felt most of the career when you're out
there and you feel like you're in
complete control and you can do anything
you want and you know you're just gonna
dominate the guy what is very
uncomfortable when you're on the edge
and you just feel like i don't know if i
have an answer for the test and uh you
know you've got to be out there and a
lot of it you know everyone
you can get exposed pretty quickly in
the nfl uh you being a former jag i just
uh i'm curious how's morale with the
jacksonville jaguars tony after two
weeks
well you have to ask what group of
people are you talking fans organization
or players because i think i think the
fans are um
ringing their hands because you sign you
know you get urban meyer you get trevor
lawrence and there was a
there was a buzz and people were so
excited this offseason and camp and
everyone's talking about you know here's
the new era
and you start the season you lay an egg
against houston who everyone thought was
the worst team and then you realize well
um we got blown out by them
and you look up down the schedule and
this was supposed to be the easy part of
your schedule you lose the broncos you
got arizona was playing really good then
you have to go on thursday night after
that you played seven straight teams
with ten you know had ten wins last year
so i think the fans are frustrated it's
a young team um
hopefully they don't know any better and
urban will be able to keep keep them
kind of on the same page but it's gonna
be interesting dan i mean urban meyer um
hasn't been in this situation ever as a
head coach he's always dominated he's
always one it'll be this is gonna be a
test for him and his leadership to keep
these guys together yeah but you played
at usc you weren't used to losing then
you go to jacksonville and then you're
kind of like man i've lost more games in
a month than i lost in a season or two
seasons
yeah as a player i mean the way my
approach was
and i think a lot of guys like this it's
kind of twofold you want to win that's
the number one goal and losing is just
miserable and try losing with tom
coughlin as your head coach i mean that
is like extra miserable like that's like
just pres it's awful um but the same
time i always realized man that
i better go perform because the last
thing i wanted to do is want to let my
team down but i didn't want to be
embarrassed and so there was a fear of
not being able to perform at a high
level that drove me regardless of what
was happening
um and so i think as if you want to be
good you want to have success in this
league you better take personal pride
in ownership and what you do
and you hope that gets guys through the
season
great to talk to you and uh safe travels
back home thanks for joining us as
always ton
dan thanks for having me at any time
that's tony beceli former jaguars
offensive tackle and
right now on the doorstep hopefully of
the hall of fame and he was on the
call last night with the lions and the
packers